Trascrizione: Sara Capobianco
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Come guardate lo spazio intorno a voi?
Lo osservate con attenzione?
Io sono un geografo,
e i geografi possono fare
delle sofisticate analisi
socio-territoriali,
ognuno con il suo approccio.
Personalmente, io osservo
con molta attenzione
prima lo spazio fisico,
dopo gli esseri umani nella loro fisicità,
cercando di capire che cosa
possa corrispondere al loro pensiero.
Ora, immaginate di essere i primi
ad arrivare in una sala di conferenze,
sapete quelle a gradinate con 800 posti.
Tutto è vuoto, potete sedervi dove volete,
anche se la scelta del posto
non è così libera come sembra -
Comunque sia, vi sedete.
Dopo un po' arriva
la seconda persona, uno sconosciuto,
che arriva e si siede
proprio di fianco a voi.
Tutti noi penseremmo: "Ma proprio qui?
Ma con tutto lo spazio che c'è?".
Lo spazio era vuoto, il sedile era libero;
ma noi lo abbiamo considerato
come facente parte
della nostra sfera personale.
Adesso immaginate, invece,
che la seconda persona
è un vostro amico, o una vostra amica.
Siete lì, e dopo un po'
girate la testa e lo riconoscete:
"Ma vieni qua, siediti di fianco a me!".
Lo spazio, le sedie, le luci, le mura,
sono assolutamente identiche.
Il fatto è che la percezione soggettiva
dello stesso spazio fisico
cambia in base a che cosa?
A una relazione umana.
Lo spazio fisico, quindi,
è anche uno spazio mentale;
e noi, proprio per questo,
tendiamo a spostarvi, a trasferirvi
degli schemi identitari.
E questo lo facciamo,
molto spesso, inconsciamente.
Lo spazio fisico, quindi,
viene percepito in modo soggettivo;
e l'aspetto dello spazio fisico
in realtà si relaziona con un altro spazio
che è lo spazio profondo del nostro essere
forme viventi e pensanti.
Ed essendo viventi e pensanti,
è molto importante
la nostra storia vissuta,
il nostro passato, il nostro presente,
le relazioni, i ricordi, le emozioni.
Però lo spazio può anche essere
uno spazio rappresentato, simbolico:
se io dico che qui, ora,
TEDxMestre ha trasformato questo luogo
in un tempio della cultura,
io attribuisco a questo spazio
un valore simbolico.
Però le sedie sono sempre quelle,
sono state usate
per altro, l'altro giorno;
ma io gli attribuisco un valore
anche se lo spazio
rimane sempre lo stesso.
Il rapporto con la fisicità,
per gli esseri umani,
è una necessità
così forte, così ineludibile
che, come ho detto, noi trasferiamo
le nostre idee, bisogni, pensieri, paure.
"No no no, io quella strada
non la voglio fare!".
Lo spazio fisico diventa,
quindi, un'idea transfert.
Vi ricordate nel nostro passato -
però qualcuno ancora adesso -
gli oggetti transazionali?
Quando eravamo bambini, "il peluche" -
momento, "quel peluche".
E poi altri tipi di cose, naturalmente:
un capo di vestiario con cui ci troviamo
assolutamente a nostro agio,
che laviamo spesso
e magari ci sentiamo anche più belli
esattamente con quello.
È un processo così naturale
che non facciamo più caso
che in realtà noi andiamo
sempre in quell'edicola,
che il cappuccino o lo spritz
andiamo a prenderlo sempre in quel bar.
Quando andiamo al supermercato,
facciamo sostanzialmente
sempre le stesse strade.
Andiamo da quel tabaccaio
anche se è più lontano dell'altro.
Facendo questo,
noi inconsciamente mettiamo
in atto su di noi
un processo di auto-ingabbiamento
che è spaziale, quello mentale
diventa spaziale:
un self-caging,
perché gli esseri umani
costruiscono confini,
e ognuno di noi costruisce i propri.
Però va sottolineato che questi confini
sono molti, sono flessibili.
Tendono ad adeguarsi, come ho detto,
al tipo di spazio,
di relazioni che noi instauriamo.
Però, con questo,
noi mettiamo dei punti fermi
nel nostro auto-ingabbiamento;
ma ci sono anche altri punti fermi
provocati dall'ingabbiamento, il caging,
che il gruppo di quelli
che noi consideriamo dei simili
mettono nei nostri confronti,
il gruppo a cui pensiamo di appartenere.
Come esseri umani, noi costruiamo;
ma vogliamo anche stare
all'interno di isole culturali
con persone che hanno
delle affinità vere o presunte,
e tutte queste persone
si scambiano i memi.
Che cos'è un meme?
Un meme-idea?
La definizione, data
da Richard Dawkins nel 1976,
in un suo libro che si intitolava
"Il gene egoista",
è un'unità di trasmissione culturale,
o unità di imitazione.
In sostanza, tutto quello
che ci entra in testa:
i suoni, le visioni, i segni,
i rumori, i comportamenti.
Noi non abbiamo idea di quante robe
ci entrano in testa, tutti i giorni.
E naturalmente,
tutto questo circola nell'isola culturale,
grazie all'imitazione,
e certi comportamenti
vengono così ripetuti
che diventano popolari.
Come potete immaginare, sui social
con la tecnologia, esplosione dei memi.
La differenza, rispetto
all'invenzione di Dawkins,
è che adesso i meme,
siccome suono e movimento sono quelli
che colpiscono di più le nostre emozioni,
adesso si fanno apposta per farli girare
su Tik Tok o su Instagram.
Alcune di queste, che io chiamo
trasposizioni ideali,
diventano quindi delle iconografie,
come le ha definite
un geografo francese, Jean Gottmann;
cioè degli elementi fissi, condivisi.
E che col passare del tempo,
proprio per questo,
non vengono più discusse
e rappresentano un esempio
di quell'ingabbiamento
di cui vi ho parlato.
Noi soffriamo l'ingabbiamento, come umani;
ma questo tipo di ingabbiamento, invece,
ci dà un senso di sicurezza.
I mezzi principali,
per sviluppare questa percezione
di appartenere al gruppo,
e di far parte della stessa
isola culturale,
sono sostanzialmente due, e sono:
la condivisione della lingua;
e la manifestazione visibile
della presunta comune appartenenza:
i vestiti, le abitudini,
gli stessi comportamenti.
E naturalmente, anche,
certi caratteri somatici.
Nessuno si mette davanti ai bambini
a dire "Venite qui che vi faccio
una lezione teorica
sulle regole del contratto sociale";
anche perché le imparano
per imitazione, autonomamente,
ben prima di andare a scuola,
ben prima di avere una capacità
di ragionamento articolato e razionale.
Lo imparano dal tipo di relazione:
e le regole diventano
i sì e no dei genitori
o i comportamenti delle persone
che frequentano più abitualmente.
Perché noi esseri umani siamo
delle poderose macchine di apprendimento;
e apprendiamo, soprattutto, la gran parte
della nostra vita di relazione
fatta di memi e di queste iconografie
che progressivamente diventano
quelle che si chiamano
i valori comuni, le tradizioni,
quello che è giusto,
quello che è sbagliato.
È una trasmissione quotidiana
di comportamenti e atteggiamenti
molto sofisticata, articolata, potente.
Però siamo esseri umani, individualisti:
ognuno ci mette del suo.
Per cui i memi che ci scambiamo
non restano mai quasi mai uguali;
e per cui nella gran parte ci sono sempre,
si innescano, delle piccole mutazioni.
Il riconoscimento consapevole
dell'identità personale e di gruppo
è molto, molto soggettivo;
e in parte, solo in parte, volontario.
Non conflittuale:
ma può diventare conflittuale.
Non dipende dallo spazio
fisico, da com'è fatto,
ma dipende ancora una volta
dal nostro tipo di relazioni
e anche dalla struttura,
l'assetto di potere,
dell'isola culturale in cui noi viviamo,
dal tipo di piramide socio-economica
in cui noi siamo immersi.
E quindi, quello che conta
non è solo chi comanda
in uno specifico territorio,
ma come comanda in quel territorio.
Quando non ci sono confini per proteggere,
o per cercare di proteggere,
quello che noi immaginiamo sia
la nostra visione identitaria,
li creiamo.
Quindi muri, barriere, separazioni;
o anche separazione, allontanamento.
Perché mettere i confini
è un'operazione profondamente umana,
spero di avervi in qualche modo convinto.
Non necessariamente conflittuale,
ma la costruzione dell'altro
nel nostro spazio mentale,
dello straniero, del diverso
è di per sé stessa
un meccanismo di separazione,
e quindi tendenzialmente ostile,
più o meno consapevole.
Anche questo dipende dall'ambiente
in cui abbiamo vissuto, in cui viviamo,
e dalla nostra storia personale.
E così, essendo un geografo politico,
anche nella realtà geopolitica
noi troviamo un sacco di confini;
e purtroppo, molti di questi
sono stati utilizzati spesso
per fare la guerra.
Però, si può fare diversamente.
Perché quello che succede in pratica,
ovunque nel mondo, è molto, molto vario.
Il Sud Tirolo è stato considerato,
ed è considerato internazionalmente,
come un modo molto pratico ed efficace
di risolvere un problema
tra due gruppi linguistici diversi.
E per cercare di superare
i conflitti del passato,
perché il tedesco prima, l'italiano dopo,
sono diventati lingua dominante,
si è pensato di separare con dei confini
i due gruppi linguistici maggioritari.
Seguendo i crinali alpini,
quindi un confine cosiddetto naturale,
che tradizionalmente aveva
tenuto separate le due comunità.
Ma in piccole aree,
questi confini naturali, in realtà,
cedono il passo
all'appartenenza linguistica:
per cui i ladini sono
da una parte del Veneto
e da una parte della provincia di Bolzano;
e in altre parti, invece,
si sono fatte delle derivazioni
che superano il crinale
per andare a inglobare
linguisticamente una piccola area.
Un altro esempio è quello
dell'Irlanda del Nord.
Quasi trent'anni di "troubles",
di problemi, di scontri
che ha voluto dire attentati,
omicidi mirati, repressione fortissima,
l'esercito inglese che spara
contro le manifestazioni.
Hanno costruito muri, barriere,
soprattutto a Belfast sono più di 80
e che ci sono ancora.
E ci viene presentata questa cosa
come un conflitto religioso
tra protestanti e cattolici,
ma in realtà la protesta
era contro l'inferiorità
politico sociale dei cattolici.
Se arriva una pace nel 1998,
e questo ha fatto diminuire
moltissimo le tensioni.
Non le ha fatte scomparire,
perché noi esseri umani ci mettiamo tempo
a cambiare le iconografie.
Però, adesso, la gran parte dei cittadini
della Repubblica d'Irlanda
e dell'Irlanda del Nord
non vuole più ritornare
a un confine rigido tra le due zone.
Ma poi interviene un cambiamento politico,
che è quello della Brexit,
che quindi rivendica la sovranità,
e quindi si ritorna nel quadro spaziale
dello Stato territoriale
unitario e omogeneo;
e questi stati i confini,
da qualche parte, li devono mettere.
Nel mondo ci sono molte anche exclave,
cioè piccoli territori che sono staccati
dal grande Stato a cui fanno riferimento,
che vivono pacificamente.
Quando succede?
Quando, con poche regole burocratiche
e con molte limitazioni,
si consentono i collegamenti delle persone
e il movimento delle cose.
Perché i confini umani,
sia singoli che di gruppo,
vi ho detto che sono flessibili
però anche contraddittori.
Nel senso che riferiti ai confini fisici,
in certi casi il fiume,
il crinale della montagna,
a volte gli edifici,
vengono rivendicati
come una prova certa fisica
che quel gruppo deve stare insieme.
In altri casi gli stessi elementi -
un fiume, un edificio, un crinale -
sono una prova che quel gruppo, invece,
assolutamente non può stare insieme.
E la lingua, "la carezza
della lingua che comprendiamo"
diceva il geografo francese Élisée Reclus,
è il collante sociale principale
dell'isola culturale
perché serve alla trasmissione
di quelli che vi ho detto
che sono i memi idea.
Però, sostanzialmente,
quello che ho visto da geopolitico
è che tutti i gruppi umani
sono capaci di auto organizzarsi
con riferimenti fisici e iconografici
che vanno ben oltre, al di là,
dello Stato o dei confini naturali.
Da questo punto di vista,
siamo molto, molto flessibili;
e quindi è la pretesa
della fissità dei confini
che può innescare meccanismi
di conflittualità
perché cozza con meccanismi
umani profondi.
E per andare oltre a questa cosa
ci vuole consapevolezza,
ma soprattutto la volontà.
E non è facile, perché bisogna pensarli
in un modo diverso,
più funzionale, più flessibile;
per facilitare le relazioni,
non per difendere degli assetti di potere.
Proprio per questo l'Unione Europea,
dopo secoli e secoli
di guerre per i confini,
ha deciso di finanziare
lungo tutti i confini interni
degli Stati membri,
e anche degli Stati non membri,
dei progetti di cooperazione
politica ed economica
a cavallo dei confini.
Però nella narrazione
mediatica, fateci caso,
questa informazione è molto marginale
oppure non c'è proprio per niente;
e lo fa da moltissimo tempo.
Eppure è un modo molto pratico,
che ha mostrato la sua efficacia
di cambiare il senso dei confini,
di trasformarli da posto di separazione
a luogo di incontro e di collaborazione.
Il fatto è che negli ultimi 20 anni
il crescente arrivo
di esseri umani "altri",
soprattutto dopo la crisi
siriana del 2015-2016,
ha irrigidito tutti i confini
esterni dell'Unione:
per cui sono stati messi
in piedi, fisicamente,
muri, barriere, filo spinato.
E questo, per arrivare alla conclusione,
direi che di nuovo dimostra
quanto sia mentale, ma anche fisico,
lo spazio che noi immaginiamo
per chi, sconosciuto,
vuole sedere di fianco a noi.
E allora, forse, bisogna
moltiplicare i confini:
può sembrare un paradosso, ma no,
ricordare che sono tanti,
che li facciamo noi,
e come diceva di nuovo Élisée Reclus,
si possono cambiare
perché è "dall'essere umano
che nasce la volontà creatrice
di costruire e ricostruire il mondo".
E così i confini, come
si costruiscono, si possono -
be', non cancellarli,
però gestirli, renderli funzionali;
utili, ma certo, "niente
per cui combattere e morire",
come diceva John Lennon
nella sua canzone Imagine.
Grazie.
(Applausi)